you talked about smp earlier right you
said snp you know correlation with ceo
70 percent s p500 hits record high on
strength of tech uh and earnings cheer
gains in tesla nvidia and other
heavyweight technology names help the
benchmark smp500 index scale a record
high on tuesday while upbeat results uh
from ups and uh
ge added to uh to optimism around the
third quarter earnings tesla row is one
percent extending a record run that
helps the electric car become a trillion
dollar company i think that's the eight
trillion dollar company uh after they
announced the tesla deal with uh what do
you call it
united parcel service search 7.6 to the
top of this p 500 index after delivery
firm reported better than expected
quarterly earnings and revenue bolstered
by strong e-commerce demand and ge rose
2.6 after the industrial conglomerate
raised its full year earnings forecast
so danielle you're in this world this is
what you do on a daily basis uh
has your uh uh uh idea of what's gonna
happen to the economy change so i'm
gonna ask this question with the
conversation that came about with powell
is power gonna keep his job after
february is it gonna be a new person
coming in is the person that's gonna
come in somebody we ought to worry about
you kind of talked about that before i
had a conversation with goldman two days
ago goldman said that uh rates are going
to be going up uh no matter what uh
because to
control inflation it's not a choice
that's the direction they kind of have
to go to be able to do that
what what are some of the things you're
seeing trends patterns that we ought to
know about first of all let's get past
the s p 500 being a record high the fed
is pumping 120 billion dollars of
liquidity into the market every month
most americans that are putting new
money into the market and retail smaller
investors are putting more money into
the stock market you've had more money
going to the stock market in 2021 than
you had going to the stock market in the
past decade so retail investors how do
they invest index funds right every
dollar of passive investing every dollar
of marginal dollar of passively invested
money in an etf or an index fund is a
multiplier of 17 times because you're
feeding a beast and on top of that
you've got share buybacks right back at
record highs because the fed encourages
companies to do what invest in the
future and grow the economy no issue
debt and buy back their shares so that
they can get their earnings per share
higher so let's let's let's just
understand liquidity is driving this
train
and the fed now because they got so far
behind the inflation curve because they
refused to get out of the business of
buying mortgage-backed securities
because they set off a speculative
like
massive
the highest speculation in u.s history
what we're seeing right now the average
u.s family the first time home buyer
right now the median price of a home is
beyond what they can afford
this is higher than it was in 2006. this
is created by the fed a lot of this
inflation has been created by the fed a
lot of this inflation has been created
by too much stimulus money so the fed's
getting behind the inflation curve so
they need to tighten they need to hike
rates and by the way the u.s economy
just went from 6.7 in the second quarter
to what we learned this morning two
percent so the fed is tightening into a
slowing economy this is the worst
possible situation that you could
possibly have and if joe biden thinks
that he is
that he can replace jay powell
with effectively a socialist and have
the stock market not throw up he's wrong
and that's why the white house is going
to announce by labor day who's going to
be whether jay powell is going to be
renominated or not
trump had nominated
powell by november the second the clock
is ticking halloween sunday he still
hasn't announced this morning on the
wires biden is thoughtfully looking
through this process he's scared
shitless because jay powell
j powell equates to continuity in the
stock market continuity in policy wall
street doesn't like change lael brainard
wants to get together with omarosa and
have a party and implement socialism in
america that would be so my my guess i'm
writing about this next week yeah
somebody else
not him he ain't going to be there or
her
okay
god so so who is that her is that a lady
that starts with the letter e or you're
thinking no loud brainerd okay i got you
okay so so which is what brainerd is has
advocated for as has amarosa
making sure that you get money to all
americans the unbanked digitizing
currency how much of the current
conditions are because of the climate
what it's like how much of it is because
of powell
a lot of it's because of the liquidity
patrick it's the liquidity does he
control that is that all powerful he has
been advocating to not put the brakes on
he's the one who's pushed the situation
out as far as it's been but now he's
behind the curve how do how do you think
he's going to be next wednesday at the
podium when he's at 2 30 eastern and
he's supposed to be answering questions
and the first question out of the gate
is are you getting renominated
while he has just started tightening
policy and reducing the amount of
liquidity that goes into the market
i mean that's going to be one awkward
press conference and the biden
administration still has not made a
decision because they're a deer in the
headlights they're so afraid of this
this is the biggest decision of
biden's entire
career as president is this decision
you think he's going to go with her
he can't she's not confirmable
why is that
because she's a known socialist this is
not a reconciliation not confirmable
she's not confirmable in the senate okay
then who you can't do a 50 50. you've
got to get 65 so who could be the person
who knows okay so really is this
something that people really don't know
is this like because this is your world
you really saying people don't know you
know how they say okay ben simmons is
going to get traded he's going to go for
uh they're going to pick up kyrie
they're going to pick up who is there
any nominee any people that they're
saying that could be can we can we pull
up predict it
p-r-e-d-i-c-t-i-t dot o-r-g
next fed chair
this is vegas
shouldn't we root for the fact that he
does appoint her
because then we want socialism no no
she's not going to be she's not going to
be confirmed so then we a lot more
people they have her eyes opened as far
as what the agenda is but
but people are dropping like flies
you've lost two fed presidents the head
of banking supervision and regulation
quit early basically in protest so
clarita his that's another vice chair
his term ends in january at some point
there's not going to be anybody inside
the fed i mean yeah you can't so where
are we here
next fetch here
um 73 cents jerome powell's down a penny
on the day
lil brainerd's up a penny but there's
nobody underneath that
so if if we can zoom in on that and look
at the other people underneath it
they're like six cents no no
you have to pull it up all by itself
next click on it click it click on
that's vice chair and she doesn't want
that go back go back
the middle middle one
she wants the big one right there yeah
right there see 10 cents two cents one
second
that's why i'm saying are these other
ones electable though or no
i don't know
some of them aren't qualified to be
chair of the fed
so but you know but the wires are trying
the media the liberal media and i i say
that
sorry but it is the liberal media is
saying you never know this is the most
inclusive president in the history of
mankind there might be somebody else out
there but the but the betting odds are
completely lost but i this is the first
thing i wake up every single morning and
look at because the stock market wants
the continuity of jay powell and the
fact that they know he's a republican
he's going to hold the line on socialism
he's going to hold the line on negative
interest rates leo brainerd wants to has
advocated for under the right
circumstances
doing those things did you throw omarosa
in there for as control of the currency
i mean omarosa right now is probably the
highest trending
name on my twitter feed
that's the fear factor
she she went to school in moscow i mean
she's
yeah this is i mean she makes no
apologies for it either no no no no no
and she has advocated for the central
bank digital currency which lil brainerd
would help her implement which would
send this country down the path of
socialism but that's why she can't get
confirmed that's why lael brainard even
though she's the second front runner
that's why she's at 21 cents yeah
because everybody that voted for her
would be exposed hopefully they could
you know leverage that and get some of
those people out would you want to be
those 10 those 10 republicans there are
democratic senators who have said hell
no i'm not voting to confirm her so they
couldn't she's not confirmable
good thank god we haven't collectively
lost our mind 100 yet
it's getting there i don't think omarosa
is confirmable
you don't think omarosa is confirmed
confirmable
if if they won't
leo brainerd looks like
looks like a right wing nut ball
compared to omarosa
wow
some great options so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you